when you look at st. organization like
black lives matter it's pretty clear to
me nobody disagrees with the idea that
black lives matter the way I know this
is everybody posted the square on social
media right anybody with any influence
in government media in corporate America
in anything anybody you know agrees the
black lives matter but but the black
lives matter movement is not about black
lives mattering I mean you can go to the
about us section of their website it
says that one of their goals is to
dismantle the quote Western proscribed
nuclear family I don't think that has to
do with George Floyd you see they use
the words comrade often in here I mean
this is basic Marxist rhetoric the
founders of black lives matter worked
for radical Marxist organizations which
by the way we're funded by the open
societies foundation which is George
Soros I know now that's considered a
conspiracy but the nice thing but
conspiracy now is anything that doesn't
fit the narrative in the narrative of
the media today is now a conspiracy you
can track that knot you can track
nonprofit funding you can see where the
money comes from the open society
foundation goes to this foundation these
people started black lives matter it's
it's very clear it's become it's become
not just ideological but I think for the
secular left you know they used to refer
to Marxism as the God that failed
it was a substitute religion for people
who lost their religion you write about
religion quite a lot it seems to me that
beyond the scientific and even beyond
the political dimension of the lockdowns
of the riots we're seeing something
that's actually got a religious tone to
it it's because the the misdiagnosis
that conservatism has had yeah and the
American Church has had is really what
is progressivism yeah and we have
treated it because we see it largely
manifested in a political party we have
treated it as a political ideology or a
political construct and it is not that
those those those are really the
outcomes of what it truly is it is the
it is it is the marci own arias it is
the it is the spirit of this age it's
the Pelagius it's the heresy of this era
these are for for the people who are not
as familiar yes you're talking about
some of the the great heretics yes time
yes
yeah they'd be in the Hall of Shame they
would in the area we can help arias is
well-known in particular because at the
Council of Nicaea he got punished every
Christmas I put out that gift that says
I came to give kids presents and punch
heretics in the face and I'm all out of
presents and and that's what this is it
is this it's the it has its own
ecclesiology yeah the the government is
government is God not God yeah it has in
the state is the substitute for the
church it determines the moral and life
view of the people it is it is a it is
the substitute religion of the era it's
the fulfillment of what Chesterton once
said which is that when the government
removes the God the government will
become the god that's right and that's
what and progressivism is is the
religious the manifestation of that
urging that ultimately there has to be
something we have we you notes that
Blaise Pascal we all have that God
shaped hole in the heart yeah
something you can't replace something
with nothing if you remove God right you
saw this in the French Revolution if
we're going to tear down the Cathedral
of nortre Dom and we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna take the the clergy in
the reign of terror to the guillotine
yeah then the goddess of reason will
take its place and they did that is
exactly what they did and that's what's
occurring here and the manifestation of
reason that's why they say I believe in
science yeah the science that says
there's 57 genders right the science
that's been that's wrong on global
warming sciences as a baby is not a baby
that's right the science that says that
we just discussed with kovin 19 and
because in the end it's not science but
scientism yeah the idea that science
conjures up truth rather than discovers
it and so to today's progressives Newton
basically if you take what they're
saying to it's most logical conclusion
we knew gravity didn't exist until the
apple fell on Newton's head all right
right so Newton doesn't discover
objective truth he conjures it yes he he
speaks it into existence i I need I
desire for this thing to be true yeah so
I must come up with a system that gives
me that truth well and that's what
progressivism provides for people even
this word science I think is key here
right the word science for most of its
history has referred to knowledge that's
the word it comes from the Latin word
for knowledge right
this trick of modernity is they've taken
the word for all knowledge you know
you'd refer to philosophy as science
you're and you've truncated it you've
you've shrunken it down to just refer to
one's very specific materialist
empirical method yeah and that is now
being exalted as all of human knowledge
and the kind of irony of that which you
point out is the conclusions are going
way beyond the scope of science to the
point that now we're saying men can be
women and babies aren't babies and it's
taken on yet again nature abhors a
vacuum mhm this religious role it's it's
how they acquire salvation and and
salvation is really in this case
self-actualization its emote therefore I
am I want therefore I am I desire
therefore I am and I can bend this world
into the desires urges and wants that I
have listened I mean I'm a sinner that's
why I needed a savior all right I've
deal with temptation and those sorts of
things all the time yeah but but the
fact that I recognized that indicates
that I admit I'm flawed so that I can't
change the world to what I want it to be
the modern American Left believes that
they can and if you don't agree then
you'll be made to care and they and and
and and that's why you also see it's
always the group's they claim they're
about to save that are always the most
punished right by by their schemes well
as the irony right but the way you're
talking to me you're speaking in a very
traditional Christian context that
original sin and mankind has fallen and
you know there's sin and death pervade
the world okay I need a redeemer right
it does seem like there's an analogue in
today's left the analog is in the way
they talk about politics specifically
all these riots mhm they talk about
white privilege it seems to me the white
privilege or you know the kneeling down
and the asking for forgiveness or
genuflect i genuflecting i mean or even
beyond that into environmentalism the
recycling the carbon tax credit really
seems to be like a sale of indulgences
yes yes all of that seems to be a
substitute religion so the more say it
may be a counterfeit or a counterfeit
word if you'd like to so how should
conserve when the left talks I mean I
want to give them the benefit of the
doubt I want to think they're actually
just sort of ignorant they know now what
they do when they come to a conservative
and say you have white privilege I have
white privilege I know what I feel it my
bones
how should conservatives respond knowing
that what they feel is an actual
religious longing they're just getting
it wrong I think one of the tactical
things that I'm not big in telling us we
have to adjust to what the left does I
affect by the fact I think we do that
way too often do we too much of
conservative media is let's find out
what stupidity they say and then she's
just counter it as opposed to what's our
actual narrative then yeah right I mean
if we ever get rid of their narrative
what narrative do we want instead right
but this is one case where I do think we
have to react to the reality of the era
in which we live in in previous
generations the conversation that you're
asking me about would begin with and a
debate over which objective truth is
true or which person's idea of objective
truth is true right and then you would
try to close the argument with a
personal testimony or a story to kind of
put an emotional seal on that on that
story we now live in an era of
post-modernism we don't even agree that
there's dueling objective truths right
so I think we actually have to reverse
this discussion I think we have to start
with the personal appeal in the
testimony and then once we establish a
personal credibility then we can get to
where were this mic my testimony
confirms that this objective truth
exists so for example in my story I'm a
kid born to a 15 year old mom all right
she almost aborted me in January of 1973
when we had this thing called roe v--
wade and then just decided she couldn't
bring herself to do it
46 years later she tell you I'm the best
mistake she ever made okay but we were
on food stamps we ride a DC I was on
reduced lunches in school I remember
kind of you know the shame of that you
know and when because there was
different tickets that went along with
those kinds of things either did a very
abusive stepdad at times growing up as
well
I once failed the quick trip convenience
store managerial exam because I flunked
out of college because they don't hand
out degrees for majoring in super Tecmo
Bowl apparently alright and not going to
class and so I tried to get a job as an
assistant manager at quick trip a big
convenience store
Chane in the Midwest I flunked the exam
because I could remember how to add and
subtract and multiply and divide
fractions all right now why do I bring
all these things up tell me where the
white privilege isn't any of that yeah
wait where where did anybody just give
me something because I am white what was
it when the government cheese I ate as a
kid was that the food stamps we were on
was at the time that I wasn't qualified
to run a convenience store where did
this white privilege come from and I
think we need to be more willing and
eager to share our own personal stories
and lives with the culture because a lot
of our testimonies are going to
undermine their narrative and actually
confirm our own you know I this reminds
me of Gone with the Wind it's reminding
you've gone with the windows got
canceled right I don't know nothin about
birthin no babies okay but you remember
one with the wind which got canceled
because it depicts the 19th century
south which is obviously politically
incorrect Gone with the Wind actually by
the way it may get burned to the ground
by Sherman and suffer through
reconstruction if they're late they're
penalized for this that's the story guys
right the south yes okay but Gone with
the Wind the film actually played an
important role in racial healing in the
United States right because you have the
first black actress winning an Oscar and
during Hattie's acceptance speech what
does she say she says does she say I'm
damn right gonna win this Oscar and you
should have given people like me and
Oscar for this years ago and I and this
is terrible and you guys are all off no
she says I'm just so humbled by this
thank you
she knew the significance of the moment
the woman prison the white woman
presenting her the award knew the
significance of the moments that I'm so
pleased to be able to offer this that
begins with a sort of humility empathy
and with some empathy and yet the
politics we're seeing from the left is
one that exalts pride it exalts pride so
much that they actually dedicated a
whole month to pride the queen of all
sins mm-hmm now now some people call it
the sin of all queens but I wouldn't say
that myself but that's you you actually
just see in a very basic level the
substitution a vice for virtue and
virtue for vice right all the way down
to the most important one which is pride
I mean how
much of our politics could become sane
again if we just had a little touch of
humility and stroll a little bit for the
virtues over eight about 80 percent of
us of Twitter accounts are outside the
US well 20 percent of Twitter accounts
are from inside the US and it's a it's a
fraction of those accounts that have
that have meaningful activity 500 or
more followers and yet this is the
faceless mob that is bullying all the
people with the guns I've never seen
anything like this in human history
where the people with the with the
weapons are the ones getting bullied
yeah and it's largely by a faceless mob
on a social media platform 80 percent of
Americans aren't registered to use all
right and but the problem we have though
is to the to the people that do make
these decisions in our culture it's the
city gate it's its town hall
it's where business is done yeah and and
even President Trump has played into
this it's in that I understand he needs
to use this weapon to counter their
narrative and has helped him do that
yeah and there's no question about it
but it also then
feeds the notion that this is a viable
platform for determining what America
thinks you mentioned that gone with the
wind got canceled by Warner Brothers
that same day it went to number one on
the Amazon movie charts right because
Twitter's not America yeah but what
Twitter does is the pridefulness that
you speak of the the way that I can
instantly emote instantly react and
there's a group of people sitting around
waiting to see what my what my instincts
are take yeah and hot take is on
everything and how that feeds the
pridefulness and the ego and and and we
lack empathy for one another we don't
listen to one another because of that I
think it feeds into that I think it's
feed a myopic view of history
yeah listen what you and I would think
in 2020 about race relations would would
probably seem molest to the people in
1939 that gave Hattie McDaniel an Oscar
right they were in 1939 yeah like we
can't look through the benefit of
history and give people any benefit that
out like they're immediately supposed to
know what the most ultimate progressive
enlightened evolution on every issue was
that we're at right now but which of
course by the way if that's your
position how do you know that the
progressive evolutionary stance you have
today
won't be looked at is backwards and
redneck and hick 10 15 20 years from now
actually by the premises of
progressivism it is guaranteed to
tonight regressive evil Reagan in terror
so you're always so even if you're a
progressive you're even if you're your
beatified within the Church of American
progressivism by to take your position
to its most logical conclusion you're a
racist you just won't know it maybe for
another twenty years right and so the
idea that we can have no empathy no
benefit of the doubt whatsoever you know
in my home state right now there's a
national sports story going on yeah
where we've got the longest tenured
college football coach in the country
Kirk Ferentz mmm all right he's been
there since 1999 and his strength and
conditioning coach has been with them
the whole time yeah now listen I'm
approached in 50 I I got a I'm starting
to get a little Gran Torino in me Kirk's
20 years older than me I'm sure he's got
more yeah but we've got now young black
players are coming out and saying hey
you're I I'm not comfortable you're
asking me to conform to white culture
don't even know what that means but I'll
listen to their concerns
I'm would I be shocked to learn that a
football coach that's been on the job
since 1999 has developed a little grand
Torino get off my lawn and maybe could
evolve a little bit would you be shocked
to learn that that would be shot
probably not that's Hugh Metz human
nature right but now we're literally but
there's no empathy we're not saying hey
coach maybe can we have it can we have a
Twitter account can you give us a little
bit more freedom no it's immediately
you're all racists so so here's a coach
that every winner goes into how many
black homes how many young black men
have gotten college degrees at a
respected public university and gone on
to earn untold riches in the NFL from
the University of Iowa program in the
last 22 years but but but we can't find
any distinction at all to say hey dude
you got to evolve a little bit nope
immediately we need an inquiry you're a
racist the coach needs to be the
strength coach has to be fired and that
comes from this notion that we feed with
social media the pridefulness that I'm
that because I emot-- and if you don't
affirm those emotions there must be no
reason why you see things differently
than me then your racist misogynistic
xenophobic homophobic bigot I like using
the phrase he's got a little Gran Torino
in him I this idea get off my lawn now
speaking of Gran Torino and Gone with
the Wind speaking of movies I can't help
but notice
not like you live here in la-la land no
no what are you doing in Hollywood I
hate to be a cliche again I'm the
Midwestern guy that came out here to
make a movie let me probably be an
extranet Guns & Roses video but actually
I can't we came out here my 2016 book in
nefarious plot yeah which is which was
my homage to CS Lewis's the Screwtape
Letters an all-time classic
and I wondered what would happen if we
went next level if we went spinal tap
and dialed it up to 11 and so instead of
just the temptation of an individual
yeah what if what if we had a demon from
Hell talk about how he took down an
entire culture and and so the story is
about a demon general from Hell named
Lord nefarious who was tasked by this by
Satan himself to take down the country
that's most stood in his way the United
States and he is now so confident that
the planning is put in motion is
irrevocable and irreversible that he's
gonna write it all in a book put his
name on it name names he's gonna talk
about political figures historical
figures political institutions movements
that he's co-opted and used and and and
that he is that he's he's puppets
trained and and and he's gonna put it
all in writing in front of our faces and
the fact that we'll ignore it we'll
think it's a conspiracy theory it's
silly that's how he will prove to his
master the devil that the plan was
successful and we're gonna turn that
into a movie so I know that going with
the wind got cancelled yeah I look
forward to it when when it's made and
when it's released probably won't be
released anywhere that the gatekeeper is
controlled but maybe we'll be able to
burrow into the dark recesses of the
internet yeah be able to see because it
sounds like a great yeah we're looking
forward to it's gonna be a ton of fun
and in the meantime people can find you
on to please this TV show over at the
blaze blaze tv.com as well excellent
Steve thank you for being here you bet
preciate it yep and best of luck with
the movie I appreciate they should have
a minute
[Music]
you
[Music]